[Applause]
[Music]
every year over a hundred million people
gather around their televisions
surrounded by loved ones to watch the
big game and the pinnacle event of the
most profitable sports league in the
world is more often than not played in a
new state-of-the-art stadium with super
sized digital displays retractable roofs
luxurious box seats and Suites teams
generally are in the lion's share of the
revenue from the stadium but for 28 of
the 32 teams it's the taxpayers in the
team's host city who paid to build it if
the privately owned teams earn the
stadium's revenue why are they built
with public money a new NFL stadium is
being built nearly every year and their
price tags are reaching into the
billions
this chart shows all the different home
fields NFL teams have played in since
1960 stadiums built in the 70s and 80s
have lasted on average over 30 years but
now a stadium's lifespan may be less
than two decades
Washington's owners started asking for a
new stadium back when FedEx Field was
only 17 years old though some stadiums
like the Giants Jets MetLife Stadium are
built with 100% private financing public
tax dollars have financed the vast
majority of NFL stadiums built in the
last 20 years
that's over 7 billion in public money
going towards building and renovating
NFL stadiums NFL owners argue that a new
stadium will generate new construction
jobs while the venue is being built and
all the new spending from ticket sales
hotels parking tourism would cascade
into the community the wider area and
would create a boom in the local economy
I asked an urban planning economist if
stadiums really are a good public
investment most of the stadiums we have
built in United States they do not
provide any positive impact most of them
what else you could have done with this
money let's say they are raising 200
million dollar and there is investing in
done stadium instead of doing that if
they spend that money on roads
infrastructure shopping malls or public
are things that benefit the whole public
not just football fans for team owners
new stadiums mean
in profits they sell the name of the
stadium to other corporations host a
Super Bowl and owners maximize revenue
by building more and more luxury suites
and club seating in the place of general
admission seats over a third of the
seats are premium in the Cowboys 82,000
seat stadium and a luxury suite can cost
as much as $30,000 per game the push for
new stadiums comes down to increasing
profits for the owners but cities try to
meet these demands because there's more
to a football franchise in the bottom
line residents want teams and the
hometown pride that comes with it
even for people who never attended a
game there's a shared experience a
collective enthusiasm for the home team
in one poll three-quarters of any
annapolis citizens said losing the
city's NFL team would hurt the city
compared to 68 percent who said it would
hurt to lose all the cities museums this
is coming from a city and state that
funded 86 percent of their new stadium
even though the previous stadium still
owes millions in debt t waters they have
successfully tied this stadium to a
civic pride and and that's why enough
the culture of spending public money on
these state is thriving when cities
refuse to build new stadiums owners
threatened to move their teams to
somewhere that will that's what happened
in 2016 the st. Louis and 2017 to San
Diego and Oakland
new stadiums aren't the economic
powerhouses owners promise they'll be
but as long as there are more cities
that want a home team than there are
franchises it looks like the taxpayers
are gonna keep footing the bill